[Musique]
france info à quoi ressemblera le grand
débat national le gouvernement se réunit
en séminaire cet après midi pour en
discuter et la sphère n'est pas simple
au lendemain de l'annoncé du retrait de
chantal jouanno alors qui va participer
quelles seront les sujets qui seront
évoqués
quels sont ceux qui sont interdits que
faire des conclusions aussi conclusion
il ya faudra-t-il organiser un
référendum national derrière autant de
questions qu'il va falloir trancher sur
lequel est bien on va se pencher avec
nos invités
bonjour mathieu klein mon genre
président du conseil départemental de
meurthe et moselle
vous êtes socialiste que bruno belin
bonjour bonjour vous êtes les
républicains président du conseil
départemental de la vienne laitiers à
l'origine des états généraux de la
ruralité qui ont lieu en 2015
et puis catherine son bonjour bonjour
député la république en marche du nord
référence régionale pour le grand débat
national pour la région des des hauts de
france
commençons avec vous qui pourrez
participer tous ceux qui le souhaitent
faut-il un tirage au sort citoyens est
ce que ce débat doit prendre la forme
d'une multitude de débats dans toutes
les communes quel est le bon échelon qui
doit participer
catherine au son alors on va reprendre
les annonces du président de la
république le bon échelon sais c'est
l'échelon local
il a il a souhaité que mes locales ces
lois c'est à dire les maires donc c'est
c'est le début du travail des
parlementaires de prendre contact avec
les maires de se mettre à disposition
parce que ce sont les élus locaux qui
connaissent bien leur territoire qui
connaît bien aussi le la formes que peut
prendre ce débat qui peut être diverses
et variées mais voilà les clans se
situera au niveau des communes et des
maires bon mathieu klein est ce que
c'est un bon échelon est ce que se
tourner vers les mers c'est pertinent le
côté toujours très pertinent là c'est un
peu la fonction de pompier qui est qui
est sollicité de l'élu local mais il
quitte aussi pertinents c'est d'apporter
de véritables réponses moi je pense
qu'il faut que ce débat ils sont ouverts
à tout le monde ne peut pas s'agir d'un
débat réservé à quelques-uns il faut que
chacun puisse prendre la parole et
et qu'ils donnent finalement des
indications sur les sujets que nous
connaissons au quotidien comme par
exemple les territoires en difficulté
les territoires ruraux oubliez vous les
avez cité tout à l'heure la question par
exemple de l'insertion des personnes qui
vivent avec le rsa ou au chômage
la question de l'accès à l'emploi des
plus jeunes et des liquides cette
formation c'est ce que nous vivons au
quotidien et donc nous avons
effectivement des choses à dire et je
crois que la parole que nous pouvons
accompagner celle de nos concitoyens
elle doit être entendu parce que sinon
ça donnera le sentiment que les seules
réponses politiques à ce mouvement sont
des réponses qui sont issus de
mouvements violents or il ya la parole
des idées l'onep il ya la parole de tous
ceux qui ne mettent pas d'idée jaune sur
le pare brise mais qui sont qui ont
aussi beaucoup de choses à dire
bruno belin les maires vont donc être
mises à contribution
est ce que tout le monde doit pouvoir
participer à ce débat ou est-ce qu'il
faut passer par des tirages au sort
parce que ça risque de faire beaucoup de
monde quoi sinon on peut pas faire un
tamisage moi je rejoins complètement mon
collègue et ami mathieu klein mans que
tous ceux qui ont envie de contribuer
puisse contribuer et la voix des
territoires elle est capital parce que
c'est bien souvent la voix d'élus
pragmatique il peut pas y avoir les
oubliés de la république et notamment la
ruralité se sont souvent par
l'éloignement par le manque
d'équipements par les carences parfois
sur des sujets aussi simple que le
numérique ou le sport
les questions de mobilité donc il faut
que tous ceux qui ont quelque chose à
apporter
ça peut paraître un départ géré par
l'élite c'est forcément un débat qui
vient justement des territoires après il
faut les jeux soient claires il faut pas
que les élus locaux s'ils sont parmi les
organisateurs soient aussi ceux qui
seront responsables qui seraient
responsables si telle ou telle chose se
passait mal donc nous devons être
contributeurs parce que nous vivons au
quotidien ce que tous vivent au
quotidien et et bien ivan herman nous
allons y participer catherine hausse on
entend un les maires mis à contribution
l'échelon local
prenons un exemple très simple un dans
le 15e arrondissement de paris à 280
mille habitants
bien que la l'échelon municipal eux pas
le bon ça veut dire quoi il faut
multiplier les réunions un petit peu
partout est ce qu'il faut faire du
tirage au sort est ce qu'il faut mettre
en place des plateformes numériques où
les citoyens pourront intervenir on peut
dire plus directement à l'heure actuelle
de nos réflexions au sein du groupe
parlementaire en marche on est sûr
d'abord ne pas réinventer le fil à
couper le beurre il ya des choses qui
existent dans la société il ya des
comités de quartier il ya des mairies de
quartier il ya des conseils citoyens
toutes les initiatives sont bonnes à
prendre
je rappelle aussi que dans ce pays il ya
des corps d'intémédiaires il ya des
associations syndicales il ya un monde
associatif très riche nous comment dire
nous encourageons également toute cette
toute cette prise d'initiative notre
souci aussi pour l'instant c'est
d'ouvrir tout ce toute forme
d'organisation
c'est quand même avoir un cahier des
charges au niveau de la collecte du
dépeint par ce qu'il y à aussi il ya un
débat et je voulais aussi abordé le
sujet des cahiers de doléances qui dans
le terme m'embête un petit peu
connaissant les derniers courriers de
menaces que certains de mes collègues
ont pu recevoir j'irais plutôt de
cahiers de requêtes
les cahiers de requêtes n'y sommes pas
trop favorable parce qu'en fait il
s'agit de déposer une liste de deux
demandes et on sent très bien si des
demandes qui sont parfois très précise
très locale très individuelle et on sent
très bien que la frustration elle va
continuer sur ce système là donc nous on
veut un vrai débat et on invite toutes
les organisations quelles qu'elles
soient à venir participer aux débats et
ne pas hésiter à être créatrice et force
de proposition également alors
revenons-en aux sujets qui seront
évoqués et mathieu klein le gouvernement
expliqué que quatre thèmes sont retenus
transition écologique organisation de
l'état questions de démocratie et
citoyenneté fiscalité fiscalité mais
selon benjamin griveaux par exemple pas
question d'évoquer un retour de de l'
isf
est ce que le gouvernement peut décider
d'interdire des sujets jeunes et à
l'évidence non personne ne peut
interdire aucun sujet
vous pouvez délimiter les thèmes à
l'avant sans suite les réunions
publiques les échanges citoyens les
comités de quartier les conférences de
consensus nous en avons tous fait de
nombreuses les personnes qui viennent
disent qu'elles ont envie de vous dire
il faut pouvoir générer du débat du
dialogue donc de la confrontation moi je
préfère entendre des opinions très
désagréable je préfère entendre la
colère s'exprimer et pouvoir agir
répondre plutôt que de la laisser
cantonner sur les réseaux sociaux ou sur
les ronds-points donc de ce point de vue
là il faut que tous les sujets sur la
table et évidemment le sujet de la
fiscalité est un sujet premier parce que
la justice fiscale aujourd'hui pour les
territoires comme la justice fiscale
pour les citoyens c'est un levier
essentiel pour redonner confiance dans
la république et ses 7 6 ce lien est
abîmée aujourd'hui encore une fois pour
ceux qui portent un gilet jaune comme
parfois pour ceux qui n'en portent pas
c'est là un sujet que nous connaissons
depuis de très nombreuses années nous
l'avons vu monter grandir cette colère
cette frustration
donc il faut aujourd'hui répondre il
serait tout à fait illusoire de
commencer un grand débat ou alors ça lui
ôterait toute crédibilité en commençant
par dire qu'il y avait un sujet qui ne
peuvent être abordés ou que certaines
solutions sont par avance écartée bruno
belin il faut pouvoir parler de tout
comment ça se passait aux états généraux
de la ruralité mais nous avions défini
au départ peut-être une quarantaine de
deux thèmes d'audition et effectivement
nous sommes arrivés à centif parce que
nous sommes partis du principe qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas y avoir de nom sujet et
que tous ceux qui voulaient apporter une
contribution
je suis à de la santé et de la mobilité
et l'accès au territoire des équipements
du numérique que toutes les
contributions étaient forcément les
bienvenus c'est ainsi qu'on est arrivé à
110 contribution ouvertes libres et
c'est ce qu'il faut absolument que ça se
fasse y'a pas de mauvais sujets ton que
vous continuerez vous fermerez les
portes de débat vous aurez forcément des
mécontents et vous ne réglerez pas le
problème de l'explication de l'action
publique donc il faut beaucoup de
pédagogie pour qui beaucoup de pédagogie
phr avant tout beaucoup d'écouté mais je
crois que ça serait une bonne chose pour
la crédibilité de l'action publique
bruno belin catherineau sont mathieu
klein vous restez avec nous on laisse
passer l'info et on se retrouve juste
après
france info qui quoi comment à quoi sont
à quoi ressemblera le grand débat
national c'est ce dont nous parlons avec
le socialiste mathieu klein président du
conseil départemental de meurthe et
moselle le républicain à bruno belin
président du conseil départemental de la
vienne et puis la députée république en
marche du nord catherine o sont
catherine haution vous vous l'entendez
un difficile d'interdire un sujet or le
gouvernement a déjà prévenu qu' on ne
pourrait pas parler de liesse f pas
question non plus d'évoquer la peine de
mort le mariage pour tous la pma liveu g
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'à la
république en marchant on se méfie du
peuple non d'abord on n'est pas interdit
d'aborder les sujets mais il est
important aussi d'envoyer un message
fort sur des cordes et des avancées de
notre société sur lesquels il n'est pas
question de revenir
évidemment il n'est pas question de
revenir sur la peine de mort dans notre
pays il n'est pas question de revenir
sur le mariage pour tous dans notre ping
fondation brûlures sur l'abolition du ss
non plus alors les gars c'est moi je
pense qu'il faut le débat il faut le
débat parce que comme l'entrée bien dit
monsieur klein et monsieur l'un et il
faut qu' il faut que les français
participe à ce débat parce que je pense
qu'au niveau de la fiscalité
il ya aussi une douleur de la part de
nos concitoyens parce que les choses ne
sont pas toujours compris la fiscalité
c'est quand même quelque chose de très
compliqué et donc je pense que la
participation aux débats elle sera
importante parce que elle sera aussi
l'occasion pour les concitoyens de jeu
pendent d'apprendre des choses sur sur
notre fiscalité parce qu'ils ont
vraiment l'impression d'être opprimé
pour pour qui c'est difficile le
paiement des impôts c'est toujours
douloureux qui en plus on rentre dans
une année particulière puisque le
prélèvement à la source se met en place
bon voilà on surveille au fil de l'eau
commence et c'est très important la
fiscalité pardon de vous couper mais le
ton de vous est contré comptez 4
innocent on imagine qu'il y aura des
conclusions à ces débats qu'est ce qu'on
doit vont faire rien c'est impossible
un projet de loi immédiatement et est ce
que les parlementaires en rond à ce
moment là le dos
s'y opposer un référendum un travail des
parlementaires effectivement à avoir
là-dessus
il faut que les parlementaires se
saisissent des de ses remontées qui vont
qui vont être faites et on peut très
bien effectivement aboutir un projet de
loi sur des thématiques qui auront été
abordés fortement et qui seront qui sont
remontés de tout on aura des choses qui
vont ressortir de partout et je pense
que oui le en tout cas moi si c'est la
parlementaire qui vous parle il faut que
les parlementaires se réapproprie et
soit force de proposition pour pour
l'exécutif assez paradoxal à mathieu
klein qu'est ce que vous en pensez qu
est ce qu il faut faire des conclusions
de ce débat national
d'abord il faut séparer ce qui relève
aujourd'hui de la transformation de la
manif pour tous en manip pour tous et je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec l'idée
qu'il faut écarter le retour à sur le
mariage pour tous sur la peine de mort
ce sont des valeurs qui ne sont jamais
abordées dans le débat actuel parler
gilet jaune
donc ça c'est important de le clarifier
ensuite nous avons eu il ya quelques
minutes qui seule est en bois en parler
de tout mais ça ou non mais il faut
pouvoir en parler il faut pouvoir en
parler mais il faut aussi pouvoir dire
qu'on ne se laisse pas instrumentaliser
parce qu'il ya une consultation du
conseil économique et social et
environnemental qui a été squattée par
les militants de la manif pour tous ne
veut pas dire que ça devient un sujet à
nouveau pour la société parce que -
jeanjean entend bien avec les légions de
personne n'en parle ensuite les caisses
qui s'en sert alors de ces conditions il
faut il faut évidemment les soumettre à
des évolutions soient parlementaires
soit référendaire mais au point où nous
en sommes aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas dire à la fin du grand
débat et bien merci pour tous au revoir
et à la prochaine phase aller je pense
que personne ne l'a à l'esprit je ne
sais pas moi ensuite si selon la nature
des propositions qui seront faites il
faudra passer par un référendum ou par
des évolutions spéciaux on revient sur
la fiscalité un instant la fifa on parle
de l'iace est très important mais y'a
pas que six essais ce la fiscalité
locale est très injuste
aujourd'hui les territoires sont très
inégaux ont des richesses très
inégalement des moyens de mener leur
politique très inégaux gour donc comment
répondre à cela nous attendons depuis
longtemps des évolutions et qui ont un
impact sur le pouvoir d'achat et sur la
qualité de vie sur les mobilités
donc tout ça il faudra des réponses et
des réponses très forte
bruno
1 qu'est ce qu'il faut faire des
conclusions de ces débats à venir
moi je suis un peu inquiet parce qu'on
en a parlement où une assemblée
nationale qui est aujourd'hui de paru
non cumul des mandats
complètement déconnecté parfois des
réalités locales on a bien vu que la
carabistouilles de la taxe d'habitation
nappe qui a rien que les élus locaux
sont aujourd'hui inquiets les moyens de
mener leur politique et alors que la
première réponse est forcément une
réponse locale c'est dans la proximité
dans la cohésion sociale qu'on va
pouvoir apporter des réponses à nos
concitoyens
donc on a besoin du prime du territoire
on a besoin de la proximité
j'ai peur que ce débat national si le
débouche par un débat parlementaire on
part une réponse serait parlementaire ne
correspondent pas aux besoins du
territoire et donc aux besoins des
habitants de ce pays
ça veut dire que un référendum serait
une meilleure solution mais un
référendum on sait très bien depuis
napoléon iii que te prends des questions
si vous mettez une question sur un si
vous êtes vous pour ou contre la
suppression de la députation vous aurez
99 8% de pour la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation et après on vient de quoi
demain
c'est ça la question c'est où on fait
quoi demain commencé en sorte que nos
écoles fonctionnent dans les territoires
ruraux comment faire en sorte que nos
routes départementales soit sécurisé
entretenu pour permettre le flux entre
les habitants et des zones de guerre
économique où il ya l'emploi part que
c'est ça finalement les vraie question
c'est comment on vit mieux demain
comment nous aurons un avenir
c'est ça qui compte aujourd'hui et c'est
ça qu'on doit apporter comme réponse et
c'est la responsabilité de l'ensemble
des élus et moi je suis prêt m'y
associer si effectivement on est dans le
pré dans le concret et non pas dans des
grands débat fumeux catherine o som je
voulais c'est loin de la fin comment
faire pour que ce grand débat ne fasse
pas un grand flop je pense qu'ils sont
mobilisés il faut il faut pas hésiter à
les voir tous les acteurs de la société
parce qu'il ya quand même des gens qu'on
entend pas beaucoup depuis le début et
voilà moi j'appelle tout le monde chaque
citoyen dans dans son individualité dans
son organisation qu'elle soit syndicales
ou associatives à venir participer et à
se saisir et être force de proposition
pour notre pays est bien en tout cas
merci à tous les trois quatre rhinos ont
débuté la république en marche du nord
mathieu klein président socialiste du
conseil départemental de meurthe et
moselle
et puis bruno belin président les
républicains du conseil départemental de
la vienne voilà pour ce premier dossier
du 12 14